six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go next
to our caller from the nine one nine
area code who's calling today from nine
one nine this is me David that is you
fantastic hey David my name is Joe I am
from Raleigh North Carolina hey Joe and
I actually had a quick I had a quick
question for you I heard a rumor that I
could not found out online
were you ever a student of Professor
Richard Wolff oh yeah yeah I mentioned
that in almost every one of my
interviews with him I had him for
introductory macro at the University of
Massachusetts in 2000 must have been
2003 I guess oh wow so that leads into
my question how are you still capitalism
and the guys barely in the way he
explains how he wants to implement
socialism and I would assume that you're
not so ardently against this concept of
like worker cooperatives right no no I
have no problem with worker coops at all
I mean listen do you have just having
one class with someone in college make
you fully buy into the full extent of
their ideology I don't mean I don't I
don't think so like I had his car and I
more or less I'm more I'm more or less I
was being a little glib obviously but
I'm just explaining that I I really do
think that his idea of converting over
to a worker cooperative style form of
socialism is what an ideal system that I
would want and I was curious what your
problem would be with converting that
kind of a style of system where we take
out this connection between employer and
employee and his entire concept
conception of what socialism is I'm all
for democratizing the workplace I think
that for any company that wants to do
that and believes that that's how it
would be best run like that's fantastic
and there are companies that have done
it and it works for them there are
companies that have done it and then
have changed their minds because it
didn't work so well I'm completely open
to all of that but my broader economic
view is social democracy where
democratization of individual workplaces
is great but I still am okay with a
system that is a very well regulated
redistributed form of capitalism which
is not what we have here in the United
States to be clear right
so my question would be is I don't
understand what its inherent in
capitalism to that exactly what exactly
is inherent gabilan that you would like
to keep well I so when I look at if you
look at any of the pieces that sort of
distinguish free-market capitalism
real social democracy and an actual
socialist system when it comes to
private property when it comes to
taxation when it comes to
entrepreneurship and and private
business I aligned with social democracy
which is an extremely well regulated
form of capitalism not with socialism I
mean I guess we're sort of like we're
going circular here in a sense but I
sort of outline my well I know I know
I'm sure you're aware that like Marx
distinguishes between you know personal
property and private property and not
necessarily everybody does be you know
like a fundamental like the state would
like not like a soviet-style system
that's not a lot you know most people
would advocate for I think most soldiers
would have to Kate for like community
land grands
like I said worker cooperative style
programs like for example in Italy I
think they have something to the effect
of like you like nine people can get
together and take their all their total
amount they would getting social welfare
for that year and start a worker crop is
like those are the other kinds of
programs that socialists would want here
so I've once again I'm not quite
understanding what what yes so that
example I am not in favor of the
government saying if you start a
business and you hire at any one that
business now must be shared ownership
with everybody you hire like I find that
to be an authoritarian imposition from
government so I'm all for businesses
deciding that's what they want to do I'm
all for people going into business
together etc but I would not be for a
government saying any businesses that
are started need to have you know
socialized to ownership like that I'd
I'm just not for that okay I understand
that I I think that that that would be
more of an option they said if you're
giving if the government is giving you a
grant to do something it's a Sarah
forcing you don't force the structure of
that either you can do different forms
of socialized structuring within that
system so I I understand your your
concept of that but I appreciate you
taking the call and I've been actually
trying to call you for almost three
weeks straight John an ask you this
question I really appreciate taking my
call all right thank you yes it can be
tough to get on but I'm glad that you
did and appreciate the phone call let's
take a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones don't hang up if
you're holding don't hang up if you're
holding because I am going to take more
calls right after this